y simular un asalto próximo a la
frontera con belarús
este fue el entrenamiento que las tropas
ucranianas realizaron en el primero de
10 días de ejercicios militares buscan
prepararse ante un eventual ataque del
lado bielorruso
y es que esta nación vecina en conjunto
con rusia también realiza ejercicios que
la otan calificó como el mayor
despliegue militar desde la guerra fría
las maniobras dirigidas por el kremlin
también se desarrollan en el mar negro
donde participan 140 buques y casi
10.000 soldados incrementando la
atención sobre occidente desde varsovia
en una visita a las tropas británicas de
contingente de la otan el primer
ministro boris johnson lanzó una nueva
advertencia
de ocurrir el absurdo que rusia comete
el error catastrófico de invadir
cualquier parte de ucrania
benidorm y el ejército ucraniano que
cuenta con unos 200 mil 250 mil soldados
en reserva luchará y habrá un
derramamiento de sangre creo que todos
en rusia deberían entenderlo esto han de
estar por su parte rusia continúa
exigiendo garantías de seguridad a los
países de la otan y tras un encuentro
con la secretaria de exteriores
británica el canciller ruso sérguei
lávrov mostró su frustración
estoy decepcionado de que lo que tenemos
sea una conversación entre una persona
muda y otra sorda
parece que escuchamos pero no escuchamos
nuestras explicaciones más detalladas
han caído en terreno no preparado
lávrov calificó de drama el despliegue
de tropas que occidente ha realizado en
los últimos días como respuesta al pie
de fuerza ruso en la frontera ucraniana
a su vez el canciller alemán olaf scholz
reiteró que el diálogo es el camino pero
cualquier agresión rusa tendrá graves
consecuencias